les cloches de l'église sainte agnès de
lac-mégantic on raisonnait 47 fois en
mémoire des 47 victimes de ce 6 juillet
c'est un recueillement pour - piper et
après je vous rassure mais allez faire
un tour vous semez tiers vrai que erreur
que capi est enterré jean cuziol a perdu
sa fille cattier dans cette tragédie
les frères pascal et christian
lafontaine ont perdu 3 est trop cher ça
nous revient le même après ça tu as ça
nous revient j'ai commencé ma journée à
10 ans savoir une journée comme les eaux
mais non c'est quand pour une septième
fois le train maintenant propriété du cp
est immobilisé à nantes
les trains qui passe actuellement ici ce
qui transporte des matières dix fois
plus dangereuses que les pétroles de
schiste qui explosent et en 2013
pensez au gaz propane à l'acide
sulfurique à l'essence automobile qui
passent ici il ya juste le rêve de
sodium aussi qui est très très très très
toxique car la sécurité ferroviaire est
encore la préoccupation première de la
population c'est sûr que les jo qui
précède le 6 juillet la journée du 16
juillet on sent une sensibilité on est
qui est palpable en fait
et à chaque fois l'enjeu de la sécurité
ferroviaire refait surface de façon
assez importante
comme quoi ils restent des
préoccupations le bureau de la sécurité
des transports du canada le sait bien et
dans un message envoyé aujourd'hui il
est mentionné que malgré les progrès
réalisés depuis sept ans il y a encore
du travail pour améliorer la sécurité
ferroviaire
le fédéral doit assumer sa part doit
faire en sorte d'assurer les citoyens
c'est sa job d'assurer les citoyens que
les rails sont sécuritaires québec
assure toutefois que la voie de
contournement suit les délais prévus
réalisation en 2021 2022
c'est dans les placards et en scène une
personne la coalition des citoyens et
organismes engagés pour la sécurité
ferroviaire à d'ailleurs déposé une mise
en demeure auprès de transports canada
aujourd'hui même pour exiger la
réfection complète des rails d'ici la
fin de l'année
il ya des gros bouts de référé qui ont
été oubliés à notre avis et on va exiger
que transports canada les respecte à
nouveau la plupart des victimes de la
tragédie du 6 juillet 2013 sont décédés
ici à l'ancien musique a fait on a fait
appel à l'architecte
bien connu pierre thibault pour imaginer
l'espace mémoire qu'on voit le lac qui
est là on voit la montagne on voit des
bâtiments marquants comme l'église dont
c'est un lieu qui est comme nous
propulse vers je dirais les beautés de
mégantic vers l'avenir sept ans plus
tard lac-mégantic se souvient toujours
de la perte de ses 47 victimes et les
citoyens ont bien de ne plus avoir à se
soucier d'un train transportant des
matières dangereuses qui pourraient
venir anéantir les efforts de
reconstruction du centre ville ici jean
arel radio canada lac mégantic